my motivation here was to open people's
eyes to what goes down in silicon valley
where it's not all sunshine and rainbows
it is very fierce and there's fierce
competition
and there's also games that are played
with powerful institutions and
you know groups of people
who
uh you know help each other out
[Music]
don't chickens have two wings
but it's not their actual wing hey
what's up ryan what's up sean sam what
is it
dude you can you can settle this for us
uh so sam uh this is ryan he's the the
founder of bolt
and uh we're having it we're just going
over this detail are chicken wings
actually the chicken's wings or are they
just like the ribs of the chicken
i think they're the way what's a
drumstick
do you think they're the actual wigs i
feel like they're not the winners
they're like this is like this is like a
such a marketing position of course they
are like what's a drumstick isn't
drumstick a leg
powerful young ben ben look that up so
you see if i'm right i think i think i'm
right
so we should we should switch gears uh
okay so ryan's here i met ryan
in uh where are we hanging out la okay i
was in la i'm at this dinner
and um
and ryan's across the table from me
and at this dinner everybody kind of
like dressed up because it was at uh the
dinner was at the owner of an nba team's
house
and um you know so most people are
pretty dressed up i see this one guy who
looks like i'm like is this a tick tock
star like who's this guy he's got
earrings he's got this like tie-dye
shirt on he looked totally different
than every other kind of like business
schmuck at this thing
and i was like oh what's up man like
what's your i was like like i'm
literally my head i was like this guy's
definitely a tick tocker or a youtuber
uh he's got this like charisma about him
i feel like that's who he is and he's
like no i'm ryan i you know i started uh
payments company i said oh what is it
bolt and i was like oh [__] i know both
that's amazing and we ended up becoming
friends uh ended up investing in the
company
and you ended up getting twitter famous
over the last few months my friend and i
wanted to have you on to talk about a
couple things
that you've done some pretty impressive
stuff at a young age i want to talk
about i want to give people the
background of that
and then you currently have some spicy
twitter [__] going on i want to get your
take on on some of those things um
welcome to the show i don't know if
you've ever listened but we have a very
casual business show yeah it's a
pleasure to be on sean i've been looking
forward to doing this and i think we
picked the perfect time
and sam what do you know about ryan
besides what i just told you so i was
googling you so i i i saw your twitter
come out of nowhere about a month and a
half ago and sean told me all about bolt
and he told me about this dinner that he
had and so bolt is a payments company uh
that is at like 11 or 14 billion dollars
in market or valuation so it's a huge
company what i know is that you look
incredibly young
and on your bio maybe on linkedin or
something or maybe twitter it says that
you've started two or three companies
that are worth about a billion dollars
including a bunch of crypto stuff and
when i was googling you today
one of the first images that comes up
it's beautiful because you're tweeting
about mobs and mafias
your
the forbes headline is meet the stanford
bitcoin mafia and it was a picture of
you and like three friends and so i know
you've got your hands in a bunch of
stuff so brian what's the what's your
claim to fame so this is the part you
don't have to be humble just give people
the the reason why they should be
listening who is this cat uh what have
what have you done what's your claim to
fame
well my claim to fame is
i think i've you know i operate pretty
fearlessly
and um
i've you know
done a lot of things that uh
that i think i've told been told i
shouldn't be doing so i think it's
business
i've been told by many people i
shouldn't be doing that would never be
possible
and uh you know we've written the
framework on culture
on conscious.org people are like who are
you to write about culture now i have
close to 100 companies pledging that
culture you've written books
done four day work week so
you know i think
we're thinking differently myself and
the whole bolt team
and i'm very proud of that
and so walk us through um
the
i don't want to go too far into what
bolt is i'll give kind of like the tl dr
on on i'll oversimplify it you might
cringe a little bit as i oversimplify
but basically
um
the way we pay for things online is uh
you know some people shop at amazon and
amazon says hey one click check out we
got your stuff saved
and then you have shopify shopify has a
bunch of stores now shopify has shopify
pay which says hey you've shopped at a
shopify store before you can check out
that way if you want
apple's got apple pay they let you pay
at some places
and what you've done is you went to like
you're like hey you know even though
those those companies are huge they're
monstrous the internet's a lot bigger
than that there's a whole bunch of
stores that aren't on shopify there's a
whole bunch of platforms like uh
pinterest uh where people go and they
find products they love and they love to
be able to check out
and as somebody who owns an e-commerce
store you i've felt this pain many many
times which is
you can look at how many people just
drop off at the checkout because they
don't want to type in their name their
first name last name address credit card
you know zip code blah blah every single
time when they're on their phone and
they're on the go and i just see like
that's the biggest drop-off in our whole
store and it's like [__] what can i do
about that like wouldn't it be amazing
if there really was
a way to just
check out at any store have your
information saved it would make a
merchant like me more money because my
drop-off would be lower it would make
the consumer experience easier because i
don't have to type in the same [__] over
and over and over again
and it has this like network effect
where the more stores who use something
like bolt the more shoppers have a bolt
account now every single store benefits
because that account can be used on all
these different stores amazon is gonna
work on amazon and shopify is gonna work
in shopify but the world is a lot bigger
than that all right how did i do out of
ten did i die did i get it what did i
miss sean that was like pretty epic
[Laughter]
we need to put you in customer calls
yeah there we go i'm down so um so that
so you create bolt and you're saying at
the beginning people told you don't do
this or it can't be done
what's an actual story that happened
there where somebody kind of told you
look
look man it's not gonna work okay so i
have a pretty extreme story
i went to one of the you know tier one
uh
silicon valley firms someone who's a
paypal led you know not paypal sorry of
payments
legend
um not paypal mafia but a payments
legend big firm big name
and i went and
i told them about what were what we're
doing
and
they spent the entire conversation
telling me
why this couldn't be done
and
that you know they actually got mad
during the conversation
and then after the conversation they saw
one of the people on our team because we
were recruiting top people was that
another company they were involved with
spent three hours trying to convince
that person not to join us
and to join other portfolio companies
and so
it's amazing you know i think everybody
coming from the payments space
the og's they have real you know they've
been in the sausage factory they see how
hard it is
um
but i think there is a little resistance
to
the fact that there could be something
this disruptive that's this obvious
and uh
we just you know decided to go ahead and
do it
what were you and i want to hear all
about that but what were you doing
before this
before bolt uh sean mentioned i dropped
out of school it's so a little bit about
my background
first job was bagging groceries that for
three years and then i started going to
the internet to make money started some
websites online businesses
ran a web development agency working for
a lot of other customers so that's why i
learned everything there is about
e-commerce
and then i was lucky to get into
stanford i saw the stanford bitcoin
group with some friends in early 2013
many of which have gone on to do amazing
things and i dropped out of school in
to focus entirely on crypto my crypto is
going to change everything about
payments i still believe
but about a year in so mid-2015 i was
like wait a second
why does nobody solve this checkout
problem if you create a checkout
and all the users who go through your
checkout enroll in shopper accounts
you could create the most powerful
important shopper network payment
network on the planet
and so like this is a site i couldn't
unsee
and i decided to go you know
realize learn about the space the more i
learned the more i realized this was an
opportunity
and so we started building
and uh
and yeah so that's that's that's the
story did you did you
did you me
you dropped out
before i mean you're probably what 21 22
you dropped out at a young age did you
did you just like knock it out the park
with crypto to the point where like
money you you fix money's good you're
good now you're gonna go and start
things did it happen at that young of an
age unfortunately it did not
i had this mentality that i was going to
build things in crypto not invest in it
which was a very costly mentality
i had like a little bit of crypto i mean
you know but you you you didn't become
you know few rich no no not at all
um so i had to uh
both had to make it i was couch surfing
like i didn't have enough money to like
even rent a place to stay
so i was cow a friend texted me before
this podcast and he said ask him like
how well like uh uh
be like well he already got really
wealthy from bitcoin is that why he's
like so brash now and so you've kind of
just answered that question you weren't
wore it and at bolt
i started off at a 40k salary and for
about five years it never got higher
than 60k
so i was living paycheck to paycheck i
wanted every dollar to maximize
bolts outcome
and just recently i've sold a very tiny
amount of shares
um just to kind of pay for some expenses
but up until about a month ago i hadn't
sold a single share almost eight years
into the journey
what about your other businesses yeah
you didn't sell any of those you also
helped start eco right uh or now known
as eco
your buddy runs it i think uh who's also
what's the name
super like impressive as well yeah
and uh i don't want to go too much into
eco because your twitter stuff's frankly
just more spicy right now but basically
you kind of helped the what just with
the vision of that or the the kind of
the initial strategy of that yeah so
i
what i can take credit for is i helped
build an
awesome team of founders
and inspire some of the ideas but
they
have really manifested eco into what
it's come become today uh the founders
there have drove amazing vision the ones
who are on the ground every day and
they've executed
and so i've played a part in the journey
but andy bromberg is
one of the ceos i have the most respect
for on the planet henry ryan sacks joey
krug there have done uh miracle work
cool and so let's talk about this
twitter thing so you came out
the other day and you you basically said
look um
you're like bolt uh you know we we've
become successful now
but
it wasn't uh without kind of some some
challenges and there's like the normal
business challenges and then there's
sort of the like the challenges of the
powers that be and in silicon valley
there's two kind of like
very powerful and in in most people's
minds you i think you picked a fight
with people that
very few people had bad things to say
about y combinator and stripe right
stripe is probably like the most beloved
startup in silicon valley respected
beloved whatever
and uh nyc is also you know the most
powerful sort of like a brand in you
know it's like basically if you're gonna
pick on a college you'd pick on either
stanford or harvard if you were going
for the top
and uh and you basically told the story
about them being the mafia and so i want
you to kind of
quickly uh can you quickly bullet point
the what your argument was for people
who aren't nerding out on twitter and
aren't seeing it because this all the
audience we have here is not gonna have
seen it so bullet point that and then i
got some questions for you yeah so the
point is
my motivation here was to open people's
eyes to what goes down in silicon valley
where it's not all sunshine and rainbows
it is very fierce and there's fierce
competition
and there's also games that are played
with powerful
institutions and
you know groups of people
who uh you know help each other out
and so
if you're starting a company especially
in payments
you've likely failed
there's
you know the only ones that have been
successful have been
internationally um
and we probably should have failed five
times over
with investors pulling out of term
sheets
when we were about to run out of money
and so we
i'd say
bolt almost didn't exist because of the
powers that be
the powers that be and
you know i think there are a lot of
other companies that would have existed
today if it wasn't for the powers that
be and so
you know now i don't blame
these institutions but but well
you're you're i i i don't know if you're
doing this on purpose to be kind but
you're kind of being vague is it
possible that you like what does
institution mean and
are you able to like actually let's
separate out right there's
there's fair fair uh you know fair
business game games which is like we're
competing against somebody that's fair
they can compete with us fiercely
there's um
investors just deciding
uh this space is too competitive or
stripes gonna win i've just got i'm just
gonna back away right so perception
thing that's kind of like nobody would
say that that's unfair
talk about the specifics of what you
felt was unfair or where you know some
some uh some there was some
heavy-handedness to it
yeah so
when we would be pitching
investors
they'd get interested
they'd say they want to invest
and then they would talk to somebody at
stripe someone related to stripe
and either be told they can't invest
or they shouldn't invest
or
somehow the conclusion was
they were dissuaded from investing
but how do you know that that's what
many they might just come to you and say
we're not hold me
the stripe would always come up
somehow in that conversation
so many of them pull me directly have
investors say directly i got a call by
stripe and they told me i can't invest
in you guys
is that bad though i mean
what if they if they were already an
investor of stripe i i understand i have
a conflict of interest right but you
know stripe has
like all the big names in silicon valley
invested in them
all right so they've intentionally
put every single
you know tier one firm on their cap
table and they even stuffed them with
small checks they're like everybody's on
their cap table
right and so
you know from and then they say you're
conflicted out right that's a competitor
of ours you're our shareholder
right exactly and i didn't even
you know consider ourselves a direct
competitor at the time but i think
they're very guarded about anything in
their periphery so i've heard the same
story from companies you know doing card
issuing i've heard the same stories from
companies doing subscription payments
and then striper brought their own
product next
so it's almost as if
they have these feelers out anything
that's tangential they make sure it
doesn't get off the ground and then they
go and build it
um
and so
is there any is there any side of you
so the way that you're phrasing it and i
would like to
figure out what what my opinion is i
don't have an opinion is is like that's
unethical but one maybe could argue and
be like well that was just a savvy
strategic move to like get everyone on
board and you know that's just like
that's just that's a that's fair is
do you do you see that side of it at all
or do you think that like the way they
went about it their intentions were the
intentions matter here
i've never
pulled a single investor you can't
invest in somebody
right and so to me
like everything is fair competition
and if someone wants to invest in a
company tangential to me i tell them go
for it we've even invested in tangential
i invested in tangential i think
you know innovation is good i have a
very long-term perspective
so when you're calling investigate you
can't invest in this company
like even if they're not on the striped
cap table it's investors too that are
not the striped cap table
to me that's just not how i would do
business
and i also
want found the next generation of
founders to go into building within
their eyes wide open
because i invested eight years of my
life into this business and not knowing
about the games that go on
right and so the most important thing
i'm exposing here
is if you're coming to silicon valley
you have an idea you're quitting your
job putting a lot on the line
like get ready
for war
like it's it's it's serious
and there will be people who do not want
you to exist and you're gonna need to be
ready to battle that
and so one of the things you say is that
which is
they basically hurt our ability to
fundraise by telling the first they they
kind of played good good game theory
right they they got every inve every big
investor to get a little piece of stripe
because every investor wants a piece of
stripe
and then they said cool now you're
conflicted out of investing our
competitors okay
some might say that's that's shady i
personally just i'm an investor in you
right i'm a fan of yours i personally
would just say
okay there's nothing unethical about
that you may not like it but that's
competing and it's like a it's a
strategy
it's a harsh strategy okay fair enough
in the same way that like i don't think
it's cool that mark zuckerberg just
copied stories or whatever i don't think
that's like you don't get bonus points
of respect from me
but i also don't think you did anything
illegal or crooked completely crooked
right that's that's you copied something
that was copyable okay fair enough the
second thing you said is
that they could that yc which has a huge
stake in stripe um
control they own hacker news and that on
hacker news people would be posting
about bolt it would get some play it
would go up the ranks
but that somehow there's some you know
editorial shenanigans behind the scenes
where all of a sudden the post about
bolt would disappear or get deranked and
then a post about stripe would be up
higher and so you posted some examples
of that now
that's i think i think that's the
summary of what you said uh as that was
happening did you
is that a suspicion or you're like i
know that that's what happened pretty
sure that's what happened um you know
because
we had some posts one in particular
that you know i'd written catered to yc
audience it was an unraveling of how we
do fraud detection better and guarantee
it with your payments which was radical
and new at the time
it had organically gotten to number one
held there
we had a ton of comments
on it just like very active people very
interested you can go read all my
comments
and then stripes post i don't know if it
was there before it seems like they said
it got posted technically before but
anyway afterwards got to number one
there started to rise
and ours just started to fall and then
disappeared
and so
i don't know if those editorial there's
also this down vote
functionality
and so you can also just have a bunch of
your employees
go and downvote or have a bunch of your
friends
so
you know whatever it is
they're able to get us off of there
pretty quickly
the the guys who started stripe the
carlson brothers i don't know them but
they seem um
from the outside
like good dudes do you think that
is that do you know him
and is that is that a character
characterization that you'd challenge
yeah i mean
that's exactly what i'm doing
so
you know what's they don't meet my
standards for good dudes uh
and so
you know good dudes is not what you say
publicly it's what you do privately
and so
yeah i i just think that like
right now you're like a loose cannon and
i love it and i find it incredibly
refreshing because from the outside
you've raised money from amazing people
at a 14 billion evaluation you are like
the guy right now and i'm just
i think it's cool and i'm shocked but i
think it's cool that you're that you've
just said that i i think that that's
i've never heard that before me and sam
both have uh definitely like a
rebellious streak in us and we've told
some stories on the plot about
situations where where we do kind of
like not
keep it muzzled uh and you know
sometimes that works to our benefit
sometimes there's some you know
um collateral damage or some you know
it's a blowback from it uh i gotta ask
you news came out i don't know yesterday
today day before you're stepping down to
ceo of bolt okay
uh
did you get in trouble what happened
here
so
stepping up
into executive chairman
i like it i like it
nice
[Laughter]
you know that was actually the truth
and
you know it's but yeah the stepping up
worked well on twitter
and uh
and i promoted module because this guy
is like he schools me on execution every
day of the week so he started off
running tech and product they gave him
col
like sixty percent of company imports
into
and just like my it's not my superpower
right my superpower is
it's creativity it's vision it's culture
it's landing epic deals for the company
so now i get to spend 100 of my time on
that so
this is something i've yeah but the
timing is weird right everyone a lot of
people online even though it's not true
they say ryan got fired because of what
he said well our you know this is
this is the start of our fiscal year and
basically january 31st starts february
1st and so this was the timing we had
planned on for a while
and so then i had some people saying you
don't think we should wait people are
going to think it's related to the
tweets or whatever
and i used to have fear about those
types of things
in the past and i think this recent
episode
has just locked me into my fearlessness
even more i'm like
eff it like let's just do it and as
everyone's gonna gossip and
you know interpret in their own way and
i actually think that's great
right
you're crazy i like it yeah i respect
that and also um i respect the move not
the the ceo part right great that's
that's fine i don't know
i don't know anything about that but uh
for the for the content that you're
putting out so
um we've talked before about
about how to pick a fight in fact
there's a there's a passage from a book
called rework called pick a fight it's a
marketing strategy and it's like a
two-page thing and i remember earlier on
the pod i literally read it word for
word because i was like this is a great
idea and i think this is when
um the guys from 37 signals were picking
a fight with apple uh and saying you
know this is not right or fortnite you
know epic games from fortnight was
picking a fight with apple
and um and we talked about you know
there's a there's an art to doing this
like first you know you can't just
completely make something up right you
gotta have actual reason to pick a fight
but then you want to pick a fight not
when you're punching down you want to
punch up at you know the the whoever is
they sort of like the power um and when
you do that you're going to get this
groundswell of a attention be support
and see other stories will come out of
the woodwork that'll make you seem even
more credible and um and you get your
name out there so like you know i don't
know how many people knew about bolt
before this because it's like okay you
know check out technology is not the
most like in your face you know it's not
snapchat it's not like a pup like like a
product everybody uses
um but a lot more people know about it
now and so
how conscious were you i mean how
strategic was it that you were you're
thinking you know what like i think if
we come out with this story
yes i'll be helping people understand
how the game is played but i think this
will be good for bolt too
yeah i mean i i think
doing what you believe to be
right
will always pan out in the end
and so
i think
this was i i stand by its decision i
think it's great for both it shows the
world who we are
as a company
it shows that we're going to stand up
for what's right no matter how
controversial
that may be
um we're going to stand up to the big
guys which is literally what our entire
product
is about
and what i wrote to my team you know
when i was doing this
i said just because our company is worth
billions of dollars
you know i'm not going to become a
sellout founder
like
it's
worth way more financially for me to go
become buddies with all these guys
right
but every cell in my body my but my
spirit won't let me do that and so for
me it was a way of telling the world who
i am
as a leader
and i'm trying to you know set
an example of fearless
leadership for the next generation of
founders
because i think we lack it like i can't
point to too many leaders in this
country
who are truly fearless who stand up for
what they believe in
and i think a lot of leadership is
fear-based
and uh i think we have to kill that
i i agree with you i i'm entirely on
board with you um i think the
i don't i don't actually think this is
my stance but i in fact it's not my
stance but at first it was but it's
changed a bit
and that's that
like i don't know if what you're saying
is necessarily true and i saw a lot of
people who used to have your position
where they're the underdogs like sam
altman and gary tan
they're not anymore now they're like the
man you know the folks in charge but and
they're like this guy ryan is lying he's
false he's just full of it and so it's
like really hard to take a side right
now because of this he said she said
even though i i totally agree with you
that they are this like cool kid group
and it's always fun to stick it to that
cool kid honestly
the things you said that they did this
is like actually credit to you the
things that you said that they did are
not even that bad like he said she said
doesn't even really matter because it's
like
if they did it okay even if they did it
it's not the worst thing in the world uh
if they didn't do it nobody's gonna know
how to prove it kind of doesn't really
matter i think you pointed out the
overall power dynamic and that's what
was important and then you just like got
your story out there about who you are
your bolt what your point of view is
whether people agree with you or not
that's their choice but uh but i think
it's actually it actually emphasizes how
brilliant the the tactic was that it's
not even like the most scandalous
you know theranose does this work is it
a giant fraud is it deception at the
highest levels no it's not even if the
accusation is true it's not but it got
so much play because of a you're a good
writer and b um everybody is so afraid
to say a word against them like i got
one of my my most viral tweets was that
i came out and said the clubhouse is
gonna fail
and um here's why i think here's how i
think it goes down
and uh
and it's because at the time clubhouse
was the darling every vc was fighting to
get into the deal everybody was on
clubhouse every night talking about how
great clubhouse is that was the only
topic they knew what to talk about and
that's why it faded quickly because if
you go on the product all you can talk
about is the product it's going to fail
um and and so
and i got privately i got a bunch of
messages from high profile people who
are like dude i could nev i can't sorry
i can't retweet this to like show
support for this
just because of you know politics but
dude i totally agree with you i like or
like i'm glad somebody [__] said it i
don't believe in the [__] at all uh i
had one person you know these are all
blue check marks do people must be
smoking crack if they think that this
thing's gonna work and so did you get
like the the dm back channel support of
people who are like look i can't come
out and i don't want to get
yc on my bad side but like dude you're
so right hundreds
you know exactly if i if i was if i had
any nervousness about doing it
beforehand
the outpouring that i got afterwards
just gave me all the conviction in the
world that this was the right thing to
do
because hundreds of founders reached out
to me
thanking me many of them sharing their
stories with me
about what encounters they've had
um
and uh you know is this stuff is
happening this stuff is rampant and so
yeah i had all of those messages all you
were missing you needed a movement
people could uh could rally behind a
hashtag yc has done this to me also the
problem is why is everyone so afraid
right
well why are you asking that question
you know the answer right
you already said the answer which is
you'd be significantly more financially
successful if you just were to shut up
and so that's why i asked you that
question are you already very
financially successful on paper just saw
bolt you're very you're set uh that's on
paper but that's why i was asking do you
have this like crazy bitcoin stash do
you did you have this other stuff i
think even in this like tiny version of
the interview you've actually heard four
or five examples like dropped out of
stanford uh that takes some guts to do
that when you don't have like
something else that's working amazing
yeah but that's what i was asking i
dropped out just a note
to focus on bitcoin when bitcoin was
nothing at that time that's fearlessness
start payments company to compete with
uh you know like one in one of the most
like vicious fields uh where everybody
tells you everybody everybody who's
smart that you respect tells you that
this ain't gonna work fearless number
two
going on the four day basically saying
we're going to only do for four day work
weeks because i believe in xyz in terms
of company culture coming out against yc
right so that's actually like
several uh of these kind of like
you know it's like when i invest in
something i've looked for like a
breadcrumb trail it's like oh actually i
see a trail of this person doing you
know really bold things or uh you know
clever things or packing different
systems i think they're the next thing
is just going to be more of that and so
you know that's i think that's pretty
cool i wanted to to switch gears a
little bit and ask you um
you uh
you are an idea guy in fact and when we
were uh driving home from the dinner you
were telling me
some different like i was like how did
you get the idea for bolt how did you
get the idea for eco and i just kind of
got that got the sense that you're an
idea guy
but you're fully co you know you've been
fully locked in for eight years doing
one idea
so
i want you to get out that little note
sheet of uh other opportunities other
things that you see that you don't have
the time to do or the energy to do or
the interest in doing but you think that
these are opportunities that exist did
you bring any ideas for me i brought
some
okay oh fire them off and we will we
will react to them so you give us the
quick pitch and we'll read it okay this
is a big one i think a lot of people are
going to do it if they hear this so i
hope they do
i think someone needs to start an
investment bank
for early stage companies
where they help okay
introduce you to a bunch of investors
you know they sanity check your deck of
materials they blast off a bunch of
intros
which is 99.9 of the value that yc has
right and they don't even do that they
don't even send personal intros
you're one of 400 companies right so now
you're you know the company that's being
introduced
you're a serial number
literally
and so
um somebody needs to do so that's what i
do personally i've probably done that
for 200 companies half the size of a yc
batch
i've done this for
personally
so for founders it doesn't take very
much time you know if you have the
contact list if those people trust you
right you can do it with one email and
then a bunch of follow-up intros if the
investors are interested
and you know maybe half an hour 60
minutes with the founder making sure
their materials are good giving them
some feedback
so i think there needs to be an
investment bank for all stages of
company building
that's actually a really good idea how
would you uh where would you
what would be the business model for it
so would you take a percentage of the
raise would you take equity would you
take a referral fee from the vcs who
want this deal flow yeah i mean you take
far less than seven percent of the
company
you maybe take a certain percent of the
amount raised
right and then maybe a little equity so
that's what i do
for earlier stages i take
you know anywhere from a few percent to
high single digit percent of of the
capital raised
and then i would take a little bit of
equity
and that's you do this ryan does i do
this
how much how how how much money have you
raised for other companies a ton of
money i mean
i don't know what that means a hundred
million or a billion or 10 million
one company can be yeah i mean through
intros that i've made
hundreds of millions of dollars maybe
upwards and they've given you a
percentage of that account i know i
don't take a percentage of capital
raised
so i
used to
i sometimes do this voluntarily for free
if i like a founder i don't take
anything and then for some i take a
little bit in advisor shares it's
usually less than a percent
it's usually less than half
exactly it's actually a great idea
this is actually a great idea yeah i
think it's a good idea too but here's
the thing so i used to run this
conference business and it was fun and
everything but the crappy part was the
more successful the conference got
meaning the more and i mean you go you
either do more events or you have more
people come or you charge more money but
me the more people who came and the more
successful my event got the worse it got
and it sucked and so would this if you
were doing this would this be like that
where the bigger it got the less your
like oh man he promotes everything or
this brand promotes everything you know
what i mean yeah totally you have to be
picky with who you know who you work
with
right you can't work with 400 companies
every quarter
and
um so sure and and a company could do
this you could start your own firm could
team up with people you can do it as an
individual founder
you can do this
um
so i think there's many ways to skin
this cat
and many different models here so this
is just a seed of a thought
how did you build that reputation as
both a the guy who knows the investors
and the investors trust and b the guy
that gets his fingers in the has his
fingers on the pulse of early stage
companies so much so that you're helping
them raise money
well the secret
that i'd share with any investors is
treat founders really well and they'll
refer other founders
right and so some do that early on
then they have a brand
and then they you know
form an ego right and they forget how
that brand was generated in the first
place
and so
the the firm that continues with that
ethos and holds onto that ethos forever
is going to build one of the greatest
next generation firms
there is
and so i i developed a reputation
from founders for being somebody they
could call
about literally anything that they don't
have to mince their words that they
could trust that has their back
completely
um and so you know my only wishes i had
more time
uh which that's kind of the challenge
but i
every ounce of available time i've tried
to dedicate to the next generation
and uh it's you know it's the most
rewarding thing i could possibly do
i like it so let's give i like that idea
i think that's a good one i've i've said
this for a while which is that uh
like venture investing is going into
like couple big categories i think i
think there's like the big brands
that are like you know their their stamp
of approval means like a lot for you
whether they're good or bad investors
don't really matter they're like the
harvard stanfords of the world that's
sequoia yc andreessen whoever else uh
benchmark whatever and then there's
niche specialists that are like oh i
know
robotics better than anybody and so i'm
gonna see all the robotics companies i'm
gonna help them and even if they get a
sequoia to invest in them they'll also
want the robotics expert in the deal and
then the last one is basically like
venture services which is can you serve
the founder in some way so if you could
help them raise their next round
i think that's a
smart way to basically
get yourself into the right companies as
long as you're as long as your filter is
pretty good uh all right what else you
got give us another idea
well i think daos are going to change
the world
so
um
and continuation of
of the spirit of investing in vcs
there need to be more vc dows
where
you invest in things
as a dao and why is a vc dow better than
a normal
you know either individually investing
or starting a traditional fund why is it
vc doubt better
because
it
relies on the collective intelligence of
a group i think
it's transparent in terms of how it
makes decisions
i think you can raise capital
uh more publicly and i think your
actions are more kind of on a public
record
um
so
you know and frankly
the best reason is i think if you're up
and coming aspiring investor or vc
it's way easier because you don't have
to spend
five years building relationships with
lps you can start a public track record
investing within your dow
and that track record will you know
talk for itself and attract more and
more capital
right what have you have you heard of
orange dow
no what is orange tao so orange dow is
basically is what ryan's describing uh
but against you know his uh his enemy uh
of the month which is uh yc so basically
what it is is it's a dao which means
it's like a
people don't know it's a decentralized
autonomous organization basically in the
crypto it's the crypto version of a
company
and um so what it is is basically they
made it where only a yc alumni can and
enter and only yc companies can get
funded so it's a it's an organization
whose mission is to fund yc companies
and the all of the investors are yc
alumni so basically it started off with
like 10 or 20. now there's a thousand yc
alumni that are in this they provide the
capital they also provide the deal flow
and the diligence and the filtering and
whatever else
and then they fund yc companies
and um and so if you're a co for a yc
company you could take money from orange
dow in addition to these other
traditional funds and with it you're
getting these thousand people
and the i think the dow votes on the
deal so so somebody proposes i think we
should vote i think we should invest in
this company and then the dow holds a
vote and it'll come back you know 70
percent say yes 30 say no let's invest
and it's like a group group investment
fund like that so i actually i like y
combinator i think that the like the
paul graham i love reading paul graham's
work i like a lot of that guys but when
you're describing this sean
i understand i am also frustrated i'm
like oh so the rich get richer even more
and more like it's just a
it's just a it's a circle jerk that that
is never ending and i
that frustrates me i don't want to i
feel like i guess it's definitely part
envy of like well i'm not in that crowd
therefore i miss out and it's also part
like david vs goliath type of thing yeah
i can't stand clubs
um
and so
it's yeah i have that same feeling sam
it just something about it doesn't feel
right
and even if i was inside of it you know
i've had the opportunity to join a lot
of these clubs and i won't do it
because
you it's also in your self-interest not
to do it you know i could have obviously
gotten the benefits of them
but you know now look at
where i am like i'm i'm free
to do what i want
um and to speak up how i want and i
don't owe any favors
to anybody and so people but you are are
you free though why why are you free to
do this
because because he's not in a tribe he
didn't he didn't basically
go into a tribe which has certain like
rules yeah but you've got
he has 600 employees who he doesn't want
to completely screw over you know like
some if something bad happens to ryan
that could negatively impact some of his
people he's got some investors
i mean i don't i have accountability
maybe you're single though to my
employees
and my shareholders
right to make make them successful
and better off
and i think that's enough
like i don't need i don't have all these
other
groups that i'm accountable to
in addition to that that you know
basically makes impossible to say
anything
um
and so i i i consider myself
fairly free
where were you raised miami florida
and what did your parents do for work
my mom was worked a local secretarial
job my dad at a small business so i grew
up very middle class
i went to
you know very lucky to get into stanford
on
you know almost entirely financial aid
so grew up without much money went to a
big public high school in miami 4 000
kids
grew up in a very diverse environment
so i got into break dancing and stuff
like that so when i came to silicon
valley and stanford
it was like the biggest culture shock
ever because miami and silicon valley
it's like
it couldn't be more opposite
not anymore that's true
[Laughter]
all right did you have any other ideas
you wanted to share with the uh the
audience
man
i so here's my general theme
is
and i'll reference bolt for a second
then i'll talk about it broadly
everything's getting decentralized
so do you think about commerce amazon
was phase one right network effects
economies of scale data
everything but on one domain amazon.com
and then phase two is you have shopify
which is all of that power network
effects economies of scale tech
scale but on one end-to-end enclosed
platform
renzo both
is the network effect and the data and
the tech economies of scale in a fully
decentralized way completely unbundled
completely headless completely tech
stack agnostic
and that's why we're such a powerful
force for commerce right that's why modu
who's our new ceo he centralized
commerce to amazon for eight years when
all the logistics came to us because he
saw it getting decentralized and thinks
we have the best approach to
decentralizing commerce so
i think every industry
is getting decentralized
i think purchasing
you're gonna see
a tidal wave of purchasing
uh platforms that help you purchase from
your neighbors purchase food locally
i think
the consciousness
of
our society is raising i think we want
to
buy and purchase things
that are good for society that are
sustainable that are recycled more than
things that are flashy
you know i think more people are going
to start wearing t-shirts
and so i know it wasn't a specific idea
but those are those how i think about
things
and with your with this whole new like
with you kind of coming out and doing
this twitter thing and accusing these
people it
it
like a a smart move and you seem like
you definitely are incredibly smart is
like
you know i'm mad at that this system
exists and it just so happens i'm
working on a solution
um is that what you've got up your
sleeve just might be
uh so what are you gonna do
to
to be announced
um
i've been working on ideas for a while
i think there are much better systems
that could be created if you think
creatively about incentive alignment
and i have confidence that you know
better systems will be created not just
by myself
but for others who may see this as an
opportunity to go build
well you realize
i agree with what you're i think what
you're doing is smart but like if i was
a hater
if i was sam altman or whoever's like
disagrees with you i would say oh well
he's talking [__] because he's launching
a competitor
and
so what what percentage
what motiv
how are they each playing into this of
like i genuinely feel this way and also
i i have something up my sleeve i
wouldn't be doing this if i wasn't
so distraught with how they operate
so
you know if they were like
a bastion of positivity good advice
um
and you know
if they were super pro founder
i wouldn't be doing this but i
fundamentally do not think they are
and so
you know
and they being y combinator
and are you are you happy right now or
do you have like a nervous energy in the
morning because of what's going on i
mean like i know sometimes when i do
something that i like i'm happy that i
did i wake up in the morning i'm like
man i'm getting a lot of hate though
like this type of energy just bothers me
where's your energy right now like
shawn's thing about clubhouse it kind of
it wasn't like a career maker but like
it wasn't that far from that but like he
was getting a ton of hate and like i i
don't know i didn't ask him but maybe
there was some nervous energy in the
morning
i didn't like how much i started looking
at my mentions that next 24-48 hours
because i was like oh man like that's
two days of my life i kind of let
my main focus be what are people's
reactions to this it was very hard to
look away from that for me personally
and i'm pretty like strong-minded about
this sort of thing and very like uh i
treated this out the other day i want my
attention to be very expensive
but i know once you get you know 20
million impressions on some tweet and
you're getting 50 000 you know replies
or whatever or the heart likes or
whatever you know
that's a flood of stuff you can go look
at about people talking about me people
saying things to me what are they saying
people hating me do i need to defend
myself it it was a bit of a distraction
for me
yeah so where's your energy right now
are you nervous are you happy are you
uptight where are you well i'd be lying
if i said i don't care what people think
i mean
i obviously do in fact i'm doing this
because i care people think so much
that i want the right
you know i want my opinions out there in
the world
and so
you know people can update how they
think about these things and uh
i'd say i'm fair with it pretty well
like the yoga and meditate every day
every morning and i stay pretty calm and
grounded
and um
you know i think that uh i feel more
uh
more empowered than ever just like i've
gotten so much love the last few days
it's been
you know 95 love
and then it's all the people i expected
to blast on the hate
who came out of the woodworks right it
was like sequoia vc
uh what you know paul sam y.c
um
and so that was unexpected i was
actually kind of
surprised at how
just like
crazy their messages were and how
hostile
they were like you know
generally
older like i think they'd be wiser
but
what what did they say or they say like
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna [__] you
up are they gonna fight you or what do
they say i mean like
what would they say
um
paul nitpicked on a tweet of mine
about strike publishing
which basically said because
i focused on that that this is mania
um
you know i was manic or something like
that
and then sam
like
just come like said something and then
he like corrected my spelling
which is like you know what someone is
yeah i saw that why he he well not even
your spelling he's a y combinator it's
two words not one right yeah yeah but
most most arrogant the most arrogant
that's like
i thought it proved my point right it's
like that's what you do in middle school
you know
and then like they might as well have
just said i know you are but what am i
yeah exactly and then sean was just like
you know called it like use just
horrifying words and just
you know this this guy the god the guy
from sequoia he basically was like
uh this you know he's making it sound
like everybody was against them but the
truth was their numbers just went yeah
yeah he started commenting on my metrics
like just like you know it's the only
thing
you know he could point like
first of all vc's aren't supposed to
comment on metrics second off what he
said was ablated and lie
about our metrics
and so another just complete low blow
and so everybody who messaged me was
like all of those comments validated
what you were saying
like these are the people you're putting
on your cap table
imagine when you'd have a disagreement
with them as a founder how they're going
to treat you
you um i actually think this is going to
be a net
net win for you
i think that like there's definitely
fear if i was you of like
man is anyone going to work with me
again but i think like being a good
natured loose cannon
is actually a
typically a loose cannon i like a good
name
yeah because intentions matter
intentions matter a lot so like if
you're a lose cannon but you just want
to hurt people that's one thing if
you're a lose cannon and you generally
want to help that's another thing that's
lovable so i actually think this is
going to be a big benefit for you do you
um are you single do you live alone or
do you have a girlfriend or whatever
you're into um
what are they saying um well
i have people close with and uh
like everyone's super supportive they're
like dude you're doing what no one else
but everyone was afraid of doing and i
find if you're doing things that other
people are afraid to do you're generally
in the right
so
you know it's a for me that's a marker
of like i'm on the right track
um
and yeah they're very supportive
have you read the book 48 laws of power
i haven't but i want to i heard it's
epic
you are doing it so maybe you should go
read it and try to get it all done
pretty soon because you are in the
middle of
a lot of like different strategies that
the author discussed you're saying all
right i'll go pick it up
yeah and the author his name is robert
green he's got another one called the 33
strategies of war of which you are also
doing some of that but this is very
interesting that you're like
involved in this what do you read on a
what have you read that's made an
influence on this whole process of yours
well i read
a lot of spiritual texts
and that has given me the fearlessness
to make first principle decisions
because when you're grounded
in spiritual reasoning
you're not grounded in mainstream
reasoning and so that drove conscious
culture that you're a four-day work week
i'm like why are we working people to
death that's not healthy our health
spiritually is very important
sustainability it's important spiritual
concept we have to push four-day work
week
and you know monks
uh certain monks
the more
uh higher on the spec on
you know
wiser they are more ascended they are
the longer their sleeves
and people are like oh wow it's because
they're more docile and it's not the
case it's because
they're actually
you know more combative when they see
something wrong in the world
and so
for me like i've found that kind of the
further i've gone and kind of healing
myself
and healing those around me and going
inward
the more fearlessness i've had
externally
and this is one manifestation of that
you are so strange it is awesome you are
so cool
i i've become a fan sean i understand
what you what you saw in this guy when
you had dinner with him yeah exactly um
dude thanks thanks for coming on
28 right 29.
27. you are the weirdest 27 year old
i've met that is what a unique what a
unique perspective it just
you're interesting
tbd if if if this battle i hope i hope
you win this battle but like you're
definitely going to win some big war
that's for sure we're looking forward to
it fight the war
cool let's go
all right so people people should go
follow you on on twitter i think that's
the best spot uh what's your handle it's
like king ryan or the ryan king
the ryan king
why why is that your name
i think it's fitting
oh my gosh this is awesome okay there's
a great meme i don't know if you saw it
but you posted another you posted the
thread about the mob and the yc mafia
then he puts another friend why why she
isn't worth it and like one of the first
replies i saw was this meme of like this
wife asleep and the husband's like like
reaching over to her and he goes honey
wake up the bolt guy did another thread
and i thought it was so funny
so people should follow you that handle
actually my grandparents always used to
call me the ryan king so
call me that growing up and i'll just
like oh it's a great handle let's go for
it
i love it dude thanks for coming on
appreciate it and uh good luck with all
the uh old stuff thanks guys thanks sam
sean such a pleasure
see ya see ya
all right
ryan just left all right what'd you
think
that guy's
so like let's separate this current
like
do i think he's right or wrong
i i i don't i haven't investigated i
think he's right maybe but i've been i
don't hold that that strongly but as a
person this guy is a killer i'm team
ryan uh just in life this guy is so
unique unique yeah
he uh he's a very unique guy he's got a
very unique style of speaking um yes
like i i usually have a bias against
people who speak slowly
talk so slow but i loved it and so um
and i've noticed that about myself that
i'll like i'll instantly kind of
okay this person's talking slowly uh if
they don't like have something super
interesting to say right away i find
myself tuning out but when i met ryan he
was talking really slowly but that he
would say one thing that would just grip
me and i'd be like wait what and then he
would say the next then it would like be
another minute and he'd get me with
another one and another one i was like
wait i think this guy might be one of
the more i was like how old are you he's
like i'm i think i bet him when he's 26
or 27
and i was like
you're one of the weirdest and you said
it perfectly you you are the strangest
27 year old i've ever met and it's
awesome and that was my exact takeaway
and then i was like i was leaving the
dinner and i was like um
you want to just hang more you want to
how about i drive here where are you
going and he's like oh it'd be great and
it canceled his uber and hopped in the
car and i just drove him around we just
talked some more because i found him to
just be a very
uh interesting person and um
you know i like the stuff that he stands
for
um which is great
in our text group ahead of this
people were saying oh yeah you know he
probably has sold a ton of secondary he
probably made all this money on bitcoin
and maybe that's one of the reasons why
he's able to kind of be this like loose
cannon say whatever he wants he said
that that's not true yeah i don't think
that that's true i don't think he's a
liar i mean but i obviously i'm sure
he's doing fine right bolt's a 14
billion dollar company now uh i think he
knows that that's right he's gonna get
fired and his equity will still be there
for him you know that's okay like that
wouldn't be you know i think that that's
the safety net but like i had said in
the thing he's got a track record of
just kind of doing things his own way so
i'm not really surprised and i also
think he didn't say anything bad and all
i think actually it's a whole bunch
about nothing
he did say something bad on the pod
though he said
i am saying that the stripe brothers are
bad uh i said
they're good dudes and he goes no i
don't think they're good i don't think
they're good yeah but that's i don't
think that's that bad you're allowed to
say i you know i don't think these are
these are good dudes i think that's bad
man i think that's bad i think that that
that is a
it's a very simple word bad and good but
like what's
it's like to say something i don't think
he's i don't think this person's a good
person that's a really strong thing to
say i feel like we say stronger than
that every episode about people we know
half as much about but like
i text you that all the time i'm like
hey this person messaged me i might work
with them on x y z are they a good
person right and if the answer is yes
that's it right if the answer is no
that's it as well now i would say
i think the things that he said that
they did i don't think are that bad at
all and again i'm an investor in bolt i
like ryan or friends so you know like
i'm i'm not agreeing with him that
they're that bad
even if they did it but that's okay like
he he's totally allowed to think that
those are [__] up things uh i think
that those are pretty much fair play uh
but i think it's really funny the way
that people reacted to it and i think
it's really good for him and good for
their brand the way people reacted to it
so
good on him for for uh using them in a
way
to build
the brand of what he's doing and also
put his stake in the ground and say this
is what i think is right and wrong i
think they did wrong uh you know he's
fair to say that even if my steak would
have been 10 feet over to the left
i i this guy's interesting that was a
good find so i don't know where in the
episode this little segment's gonna go
in the beginning in the end but that's
what we think about that guy that guy
was fascinating i could talk to him for
a long time yeah i'm older than him but
i would like look up to him and i think
that in his like you know when he was on
here i think he was you know trying to
do a good job kind of representing what
he stands for like i think most people
do if you go i think most people's
default if i get invited onto a podcast
i'm gonna go on i'm gonna try to like
you know say all the right things so i
think he was definitely doing a little
bit of say the right things it stuff but
actually having talked to him in private
he actually was very similar where he's
like
you know i believe in this
i think it's going to be awesome
i think we're going to win
and i'd be like yeah but like you know
we're just shooting this is late night
dinner over two drinks like
but he was just like i said what i said
and i meant what i said you know like
i think this is awesome i think i'm you
know this is the best i think this is
totally gonna work i think blah blah so
like i think he has a very uh
singular mindedness about what he
believes in and i think that's cool to
uh to to interact with because i think
most people a don't believe anything b
when they believe they'll hedge uh or c
they'll kind of be wishy-washy about it
or they believe when the lights are on
and then when the lights are not on
they're you know why are you applying
for a job i thought you just said this
is the company that's going to win oh
yeah yeah just in case you know like
there's a wishy-washy to a lot of people
i've he has zero wishy-washiness so uh
you know for better for women and i i'm
upset at myself i judged him as being
far different just by looking off his
profile picture uh would you think he
was not
just that he was this like i thought he
was what people accused me of being of
this like blonde hair white bro who
had everything in life handed to them
who um is going to be kind of um maybe
not as intellectual kind of a uh
an alpha right you know like this this
stereotype that it's not an insult
necessarily but i wouldn't be proud of
that i just think i'm just like a good
looking strong muscular
successful guy and i just feel like it's
unfair
well
i'm not talking about myself but like
with him i'm like well because he went
to stanford he dropped out of stanford
was in bitcoin forever so it was like
crazy rich at a young age
he said he's from miami so in my head
i'm like yeah oh okay
yeah this is like the this is this thing
that you're calling life is a game for
you and in reality he was incredibly
intellectual very intriguing i believe
him that he that like i understand that
you can be very wealthy on paper but
like he hasn't sold a lot of stuff so
like that's an interesting perspective
so i thought he was cool different than
what i thought it was gonna be i enjoyed
it yeah uh cool let us know what you
think if you want us to do kind of more
of these or less of these uh you can
tweet at us and uh you know we take it
into consideration we don't necessarily
listen but we
we like to know what you think and then
we may or may not do it
[Music]
you